Filmmakers use a lot of tricks
to up the anxiety of a scene.
Music...
Sound mixing...
Lighting, color...
And then there’s this trick:
An ever-so-slight tilt of the camera.
Even without all of the other stuff,
the second you take the world
off its axis,
things start to feel a little off.
Or at least a little more interesting.
That camera tilt,
which you'll see everywhere
from blockbuster movies
to perfume commercials,
it’s called a lot of things.
But most often, you’ll see it referred to
as the “dutch angle.”
It’s a stylistic choice whose roots
are based not in film, but in fine art.
Let’s get this out of the way.
The Dutch angle isn’t actually Dutch.
It’s Deutsch.
As in German for German.
Its origins trace back to World War I,
when the German government banned
the import of foreign films.
So while, over in Hollywood,
the movie business was booming
with Charlie Chaplin joints,
racist Tarzan adaptations,
and other straightforward,
happy-ending-type flicks,
in Germany, movies were starting
to look a little different.
Instead of turning to Hollywood for inspiration,
German filmmakers turned to the arts.
And at the time, a movement called
“Expressionism” had taken hold,
primarily in Germany and Austria.
Expressionism is famously hard to define.
But you can think of it as roughly
the opposite of impressionism.
Impressionists like Monet, Degas,
and Renoir painted things like this.
Floaty, lovely, soft scenes.
And expressionists like Kirchner, Beckmann,
and Dix painted things like this.
One more time, for emphasis.
While Impressionists were
interested in producing
spontaneous, but always
refined versions of reality,
Expressionist painters were focused on depicting
a subjective version of a world in turmoil,
grappling with the horrors of war
and the anxiety of modern life.
Figures are distorted and painted roughly,
often tossed about at impossible angles.
Colors are intense and unrealistic.
Scenes are eerie, even nightmarish.
It’s harsh and dark, in both
content and execution.
All of which translated pretty well to film.
Starting in 1920, with
The Cabinet of Dr. Caligari:
A German silent horror movie
about a hypnotist
who uses his sleepwalking
patients to kill by proxy.
It’s got the distorted figures,
by way of outlandish makeup,
harsh angular lighting,
and, in place of the exaggerated
perspective of painting,
the whole movie is noticeably askew.
But not because of camera work.
The set is literally tilted, with
sidewalks that lead nowhere,
walls arranged seemingly at random,
and buildings that look
poised to collapse;
all rendered in stark, graphic lines,
by a trio of expressionist painters.
When The Cabinet of Dr. Caligari
came out, it was a revelation.
Critics called it startling!
Weird!
Sensational!
"The most remarkable picture ever shown."
They lauded its great acting
and innovative story.
There’s a killer surprise twist at the end.
But, mostly, it was that set design
that excited people.
Those turns and tilts enhanced
the movie’s suspense and distortion.
Caligari was hailed a "prophecy," ushering
in a new art-centric era for movies.
And, though critics couldn’t quite yet agree
on which art movement it belonged to,
that prophecy kind of came true.
Expressionist classics like Metropolis
and Nosferatu soon followed,
using that same lighting, drama,
and of course, dutch angles --
this time, using the camera to
tilt the scene, instead of the set.
From there, the dutch angle
spread to noir films,
featuring prominently in
Citizen Kane and the Third Man.
Then, it broke into thrillers, specifically
Hitchcock thrillers, like The Birds,
Strangers on a Train, and
the lesser-known, The Lodger.
Which the man himself said was
heavily influenced by expressionism.
"That picture shared a
strong German influence."
By the 60s, a very different genre
picked it up.
1966’s Batman famously gave each villain
their own specific tilt.
And from there the angle really took off.
Action movies.
Musicals.
Comedies.
Even commercials.
Today, it's featured across basically every
genre, to varying degrees of success.
Movies like 2000’s Battlefield Earth
and 2011's Thor
have been criticized for
using the tilt as a crutch.
But filmmakers like Spike Lee, Terry Gilliam,
and Tim Burton all seem to get it:
Tilting a shot to highlight tension,
or distortion,
or underscore a film’s
dystopian confusion.
Keeping the spirit of
expressionism alive.